[Music]
here's that good morning New York City
[Music]
what are you doing what's it look like
I'm doing
I'm doing superhero stuff I'm calling
this meeting of the superhero animal
friends to order come on Molly
time to go oh I'm gonna be late for
school captain snowball you're in charge
while I'm gone one first of all I want
to welcome white thunder back from the
washing machine who was put in there
with a red blanket and henceforth will
be known as pink thunder personally I
like the new look
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
No why is there lampshade on your head
my owner might have given me a little
bit of catnip do you hear that
Oh your party oh I wonder what other
sounds I could make I'm home
let's say we go for a walk this is nice
first time here
yeah Oh dr. Francis is the best
veterinarian in the business
you're gonna love him he specializes in
behavioral disorders but I don't have a
behavioral disorder I can't find two
it's by human that's nuts I mean you
know I I bring a red dead bird she
throws it out I bring him a dead mouse
garbage gone no no my owner always says
you're such a good dog and I feel like a
good dog was fifty pound I'm a bad dog
bad dog we start fires
that was weird Oh sister it's gonna get
way weirder
tail ears you look so much like a
cabbage crazy whoa whoa whoa hold on now
you gotta learn how to act like a cat
I'm gonna throw some situations at you
and you're just gonna react like a cat
no punching is for dopes you're above
that the fact of life until in the face
okay
search his blood to the cops walk on
keyboard there you go
coffee on computer and down nice yes you
got it you're as close to a cat as a dog
can get the secret life of fish to eat
sweet pea what cats eat birds you're
seriously gonna make are you sweet pea
oh no no of course no bad dog bad cat
dog oh sorry
[Music]
what you're about to hear is the most
dramatic thing you ever heard in your
whole life
do any of you know captain snowball yeah
yes yes we do and here we go
my name is Daisy and I really gotta talk
to him I don't mean to sound dramatic
but a poor defenseless animal needs
saving
I'm he captive snowball for all right
gotta go but nice meeting you uh what
was it again okay you don't listen it's
Daisy whatever okay I got to get to do
[Music]
not in any way no probably you huh
you're wearing a bright suit everyone's
gonna notice you I'll be fine
[Music]
name's rooster we're going on a trip
really we're going in the car
[Music]
so many smells I've never smelled before
my nose so confused and happy oh I'm
Duke and you are hey cow Moo you're a
cow you're supposed to Oh dog I'm going
to get my tail like an idiot are you to
throw ball
oh please still evolve and I will chase
it because my brain is the size of a rat
turd okay yeah I get it you big boy
[Music]
[Music]
the separate life effects - he uh he got
the jump on me I'm Jesse I couldn't see
him because of the tone then get rid of
the cone man I would I would but my
therapist I need it it's a medical
device doctor
yeah you're cured hallelujah
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
how you pulled it off
[Applause]
[Music]
now get it get out of there
you've been so stressed lately but this
vet is gonna help you
he specializes in behavioral disorders
but I don't have a behavioral disorder
yeah I'm fine too it's like humid it's
nuts I mean you know I I bring it with
bed but she throws it out someone's in
my litter box do any of you know captain
snowball and here we go
it's no time
is he okay
not in any way No
[Music]
hey no no no this way buddy the baby is
leaving in nesco he's staying home with
me
where it's safe three max Liam just left
wait what
it's home base to all units the package
has left the building does anyone have
eyes on him
[Music]
[Music]
the first step of not being afraid is
acting like you're not afraid
[Music]
oh just this weird little guy
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]